c'est au coeur de la rue paul doumer que
petits et grands se sont rassemblés pour
profiter des animations autour de la
bande dessinée tout au long de l'après
midi les fans de cosplay vous défiler
dans leurs plus beaux déguisements
devant un jury composé de trois
personnes je suis un bel paysanne de la
belle et la bête peu après gagne ou pas
enfin on fait ça surtout pour s'amuser
de manière générale les plus jeunes
pouvaient également se rendre sur des
stands de maquillage ou assister à un
atelier de dessin avec françois plisson
dessinateur de bandes dessinées il se
prête au jeu et ils sont bien contents à
ce troisième petit groupe que j'ai
depuis tout à l'heure ça se passe très
bien tout le monde sait à peu près
dessiner mais tout le monde ne sait pas
en fait si on s'entraîne ça fonctionne
c'est comme le piano violon pour faute
pour pratiquer quoi et msa pour
l'événement une partie de la rue paul
doumer était piétonniser une
expérimentation qui vise à redynamiser
le centre ville des mureaux ça s'inscrit
dans tout un programme qu'on lance
sureau 2022 ou tous les deux mois la rue
sera piétonnisée avec différents
événements donc cette fois ci autour de
la bd les y aura la fête de la musique à
hérat le marché de noël et puis d'autres
événements qui vont venir et ce à tous
les deux mois c'est une expérimentation
l'idée c'est de voir sur 2023 ce qu'on
fait en termes de piétonnisation est ce
que on a une piétonnisation permanent
par exemple le week-end et ce qu'on
reste sur une piétonnisation assez
régulière mais toujours couplé avec des
événements voilà c'est vraiment en cause
itation chez lui un projet sur le long
terme qui démarre plutôt bien car malgré
la pluie les amateurs de la bande
dessinée et du cosplay était au rendez
vous